I'm Jeff from the overwatch
team expect buffs for Dragoon
okay so why are the whites acting like
The Three Stooges all of a sudden they
can't get through one doorway and not allow
Aria to escape I don't think so this counts
as a death I don't know if falling
off the dragon on a hundred miles an
hour will kill you but I think that most
of your bones would probably be broken
[Music] alright this clip takes place a few
minutes later boats actually analyze what's
happened in here we can see Jamie clearly good
dogpile by like four whites and then rain in the
background just getting hugged by his zombie
Aldous Lee Podrick out of this since his rod
can defeat anyone well for Jaime and Brienne
that is a guaranteed death sorry sir doing
my best who made that man a gunner I did sir
he's my cousin who is he he's an [__] sir I
know that what's his name that is his name sir
[__] major [__] theond you're a good man
if bran can see everything then he knows that Aria
is coming to save him thank you so
is he just sending Theon to die here
was up I guess how long waiting line I
didn't win no I'm a part owner I feel so
when you're alone nice ass I love how this
scene doesn't make any sense at all she has
to say the spell like 30 times for it to work
when it should only take one time it's funny
because she just lit up thousands of dots
rocky swords on her first try 30 minutes ago
no will.i.am your card this clip makes it
very confusing as to how strong a white is
you can somehow punch his way out of a concrete
grave but back in season 7 he can't get out of
a wooden crate damn climate change really hit
Westeros hard you could smell the [__] from
five miles away we appeared to be missing
a master of whisperers missing a master of
whisperers why does brand need a master of
whisperers when he knows and sees everything
while Danny kind of forgot about they aren't
fleed and and without Cox you wouldn't find me
fighting in an army if I had no [__] because
you have no [__] even heard you have no [__]
at the sort of thing you start to say once your
dick gets chopped off along with my big [__]
if I lost my [__] I drink all the time dick
talk you can suck his magic [__] later that's
like saying I have a bigger [__] than anyone
in the unsullied army not without a [__] you
don't lease your balls don't freeze off you take
great defensive dwarf jokes but love telling unit
jerks why is that because I have balls you
don't learn all your [__] grandsons don't
ruin the family with their [__] ways I don't
think a [__] is a true qualification as I'm
sure you'd agree [__] are important I'm afraid
maybe it really is all [__] in the end [Music]
so this clip is from season seven were Daenerys is
coming down to talk to Cersei and bran was making
oil barrels just in case you would actually
attack how many barrels 500 get 500 more so
I guess this makes bran the smartest person in
Westeros because everyone in Winterfell forgot
that the whites would eventually get to the
wall and they would need oil barrels it's so
stupid how the night king has this many White
Walkers and doesn't use any of them I bet you
didn't think that the White Walkers fight scene
we had in our home was going to be the only white
Walker fight scene in the show practically at
the very least they could have had the White
Walkers fight one of the main characters on
the way to the night king since they had to
go through the courtyard where like Brienne
was for example so if all the Dothraki our
blood riders and they're supposed to avenge their
dead call who is Daenerys then where did they all
go when she died aren't they supposed to come
back and kill John I've never met this man in
my life he's my brother adopted I love how Lena
Headey was making about five hundred thousand
dollars per episode and all she had to do was
complain about elephants I was told the golden
company had elephants are excellent reasons your
grace and just stare out windows the whole time
so for the final episode of the show there's
about ten minutes of filler I put up on screen
that there's about eight minutes of characters
just walking around and one a minute of teryan
showed up in fixing chairs say that we're being
generous and five of those minutes are necessary
for the episode that still leaves us with enough
time for a deleted scene and that seems this
where I lose the baby I think we can
all agree that we would rather see
a miscarriage you know Cersei rather than
having Tyrion fixing chairs I would I gave
her character much more to do rather than
complaining about elephants and staring
into the middle distance so that's basically
the final point of the video and I'll end it
with a Simpsons clip that perfectly
wraps up the devoid of logic series